So the definition is a little bit complicated,
and it involves a bunch of moving parts
like c1s, c2s and 0s and ends in f's and g's.
Let's see whether the definition at least satisfies
some intuitive properties that we want it to.
So to the extent that we're saying that Big Theta
means the two functions grow roughly the same as each other,
then it ought to be the case that
if some function f(n) is in Θ(g(n)),
it seems like it should go the other way, as well.
If f(n) grows roughly the same as g(n),
then g(n) should grow roughly the same as f(n).
Is that true? So here's some possible choices.
No, as much as we would like this to be true,
it just doesn't follow from the definition
of Big Theta that we just gave.
Yes, because Big Theta is like an equality.
An equality is reflexive, so Big Theta ought to be reflexive.
And then another possibility is yes,
because we can use the c1 and c2
from the definition of f(n) is in Θ(g(n)),
use the reciprocals, and that sandwiches g(n).